it's a real honor to introduce David
Shea from Stanford University David let
me David you want to come in and connect
David has done a lot of pioneer work
pioneering work in different areas
including wireless communications he's
well known for his work on proportional
fair scheduling for cellular networks he
is my complete fellow National Academy
of Engineering member and several metals
clock is sealed you can live anymore
I make my equipment ready here a little
bit one second
okay so thank you Dahlia Thank You
Elaine for inviting me here great
pleasure to be here I always like to be
back at Simon's Institute I spent one
semester two semesters here before okay
so today I'm going to talk about prism a
new consensus protocol that we have been
working on in the past year and this
work will be presented at CCS 19 so your
work was presented CBS 18 to the present
in CSS 19 so there's some symmetry here
very good always could have symmetry all
right so let's get to the main point
so as everyone knows bitcoin has a good
security 50% adversary' low transaction
throughput long confirmation latency so
the objectives of work is very simple we
ask the question is there a natural way
to provably scale Bitcoin so that's the
goal of this work is to find a natural
way to do that and I want to argue the
case that our protocol is rather natural
and second how far can one scale so
we're gonna answer these two questions
so this work so that our approach to
problems and following we examine
nakamoto's blockchain rather carefully
the longest chain protocol rather
carefully and we try to deconstruct what
the blockchain is actually doing so
Nakamoto loudness changes seemingly very
simple but I argued that is actually
quite quite sophisticated and we may
progress by trying to do a
deconstruction and then put it back
together again
and then scale to obtain prism okay so
let's start with Nakamoto blockchain so
we start from the Genesis blog different
miners add to this blockchain there's a
mining rate which Raj mentioned earlier
C is the block time so here I use F the
mining rate we're just 1 over C
basically and so different miners mine
and extend and the protocol is mining on
the longest chain always mine and the
tip of the longest chain in case it's
forking always warning longest chain and
in nakamoto's block change the average
money rate is one block for ten minutes
so that's a situation so the main the
key to the two longest chain protocol is
how transaction is confirmed so here we
have a block a transaction comes in and
so a naive scheme would be just
immediately confirmed once the
transaction gets there that does
or why doesn't that work is because of
the so called nakamoto's private tank so
the Nakamoto assays that if the
adversary minds in private say to blocks
it got lucky and mine to blocks and then
it can displace this to show these two
blocks broadcasted to the network and
now others will grow on this longest
chain and then this will displace the
transaction that was confirmed so d
confirm a transaction this is the one
the most serious attack on a
cryptocurrency double spend which
basically means that you can spend and
then D confirm and use the same
correctly so that's not very good so
Nakamoto solution was a rather simple
they say it's okay this is not so good
so what he says is that we will only
confirm when we wait until the block the
contract the transaction is so called
hey block deep which means that there K
blocks on top of it actually strictly
speaking I believe is K minus one block
on top of it a little bit typo here
but anyway point is a lot of blocks on
top of it and the reason why this is a
effective scheme is because in this case
what the adversary has to do now is to
mine a larger number of blocks in
private larger than K so that when it
shows it broadcasted it will become the
new longest chain but this is very
difficult because the adversary give
diversity has less power than the owners
know which is assumption here then it
would have to get extremely lucky to be
able to get many blocks in private as
opposed to the previous example where
owners get say two blocks which is quite
possible and Nakamoto did a calculation
so that's the only math in the paper but
it was a very very good math actually
saying he's calculating that for
different K what is the probability of
reversal
it was the probability that in the
comodo private attack is successful and
there's this whole table and so using
this table one can calculate how long do
we have to wait to confirmed and you can
say that for 10 to the minus 3 air rate
which is around here then you have to
wait about 25 block deep which
translates you to in 15 minutes ok so
the classic six block deep rule we are
up to here like pretty high error
probability and so if you want a
reliable system with reasonably low
error rate your latency is rather bad
okay
so that's the situation good
so far no question this into your talk
and they be concerned actually I left
the room and to get you know the
bathroom because I thought your talk
will go and cook for quite a while but
ok good you survived and I hope I'll
survive - ok so so now there is actually
two rows of a block a block has two rows
it either prove it proposes transactions
ok so which is pretty clear as it grows
it proposes transactions every block at
transactions to a larger and in this
view if you have a low mining rate which
is one block for 10 minutes then that
translates to low throughput don't
report of course is assuming a given
block size different block size one
megabyte then Loman and rate means low
throughput ok there's another row of
block which is less obvious but equally
or even more important perhaps is voting
so a transaction gets in
and a attacker tries to prove pros a
anti transection let's call anti
transaction which is the double spend an
entire transaction space it doubles band
which is trying to reverse history and
one can interpret what happens in the
longest chain Perico as follows the
honest notes are growing on the visible
longest chain the adversary is using its
private power using his own adversary
power to grow on the alternative to
history that's trying to create so
there's a competition there's a race
both sides are voting and at the end
whoever gets more votes kind of wins out
and because the honest no has more power
and you wait long enough the chance of
him where nail is very high yes
why does a low mining rate being low
through but it means high latency but
mining is independent of the block size
right like you know Bitcoin cash isn't
much throughput then like Bitcoin right
it's not interesting right you can
amortize the mining of her number
so for a fixed block as I mentioned for
fixed block size the low to moderate the
load of throughput that's a correct
statement let me leave so the point is
the points that you don't want to vary
the block size right so one a very the
block size right you want to make the
block size so you've got load of money
you want to make the block size bigger
to account for that
is that what you're saying is that the
question how fast you can actually like
parson apply your blocks
but this is just a statement it's not a
question and
interlining actually proportionally no
no you can still probably get the block
header did availability problem did you
header
we're thinking start optimistically I
mean stop okay whatever
yeah we'll come back and we'll come back
to this point a little bit alright we'll
come back to this point little bit when
we go to the next slide but right now
the statement is for fixed block size
the load of modern rate the lower the
throughput okay and and the load of
money rate also the lower the voting
rate because the votes you're waiting
for is to wait for K votes so therefore
if the minor E is low the voting rates
are so low and that leads to high
latency okay yes
yeah it's the same same thing the high
difficulty implies no money rich is it
okay
and no mining great does not guarantee
no true pyramid people can be trying to
mind a lot but the difficulty inside so
they cannot mind
okay so maybe I should go one step
higher and says high difficulty implies
low murmuring rate implies low voting
rate implies high latency so I remember
yesterday there were some concern about
keeping 10 characters in one's mine so I
thought you know having four things may
be a bit too much right so you know I'm
also around that age also so you know I
can't keep track of that many things
here okay all right so okay so we have
one option at this moment one option
which is to increase the money rate
which is kind of like or make the
difficulty lower okay right now I'm
famous I'm making so far correct but we
can okay we can take that off of the
side not completion okay alright so you
increase this mining rate is one
possibility
because it seems to solve both problems
right you increase the memory you reduce
the latency and you increase the
throughput okay the problem is as well
now already discussed earlier as you
increase the money and rate the forking
increases okay so the foking increases
we have already seen such a curve in the
last talk actually this is just a
reverse because the mining rate is 1
over C so that curve was like flipped
around but this is the same type of
curve which basis a so as you increase
the monetary or decrease the block time
then the security goes down okay and the
reason for that is because the honest
work is split the honest work was
working very hard and try to grow this
long as chain but now it got split and
the adversary' if
the centralized location will not get
the split and there you cannot sue me
with your split corn Lee and therefore
relatively speaking diversity now has
stronger power than the Ernest Snowden
and so the security goes down that's the
intuition about this okay so going back
to David's question which was okay so
what about the block size why can't we
make the block size bigger if we make
the block size bigger and keep the
nakamoto protocol right then the network
delay will increases and this morning
rate is really the block generation rate
normalized by the network delay okay so
it has the same effect which is to
increase the money Rachel okay so the
same problem here okay so sticking
within the Nakamoto protocol then the
longest chain then we have this
trade-off between security and
scalability in terms of throughput and
latency so basically the whole effort
that we're making is try to see whether
this trade-off is kind of fundamental or
can it be overcome and just to mention
there's actually quite a lot of work
along the lines of so-called deck
methods which tries to essentially say
okay we have this block mess it's messy
but let me try to deal with it anyway
let me try to deal with it anyway and I
must say this approaches not extremely
successful because the analysis is
extremely difficult and tricky for
example I think you already mentioned
your paper that it goes for example it
is not secure it is not secure at high
money rate which is a regime of interest
here and these are the protocols the
proofs are rather complicated and some
of them have no proof yet okay so we try
a different approach a different
approach this problem and I approaches
the following we deconstruct Bitcoin
scale so instead of trying to deal with
the block mess we in some sense try to
put more structure into the block mess
and the way we put structures of
following we say okay so since there are
two different rows proposed a voter why
do we have to impose these two rows on
to the same block let's try to separate
out the blocks into two types two types
and in the left-hand side these blocks
the only job is to propose transactions
and these blue box the only job is to
vote for the red blocks the proposal
blocks okay so we have two types of
blocks proposal blocks and voter blocks
the voter block sits on a longest chain
so devoted block is like the following
the nakamoto tie protocol sitting on the
longest chain but when you mind it you
include an hash to a voter to a proposal
block to indicate that you want to vote
for a particular block okay
so in other words let me just finish
this one line first in other words the
voting which was done implicitly in the
longest chain protocol through the links
to the previous block is now made
explicit by adding these voter links and
by setting out yeah I did not change I
did not change anything about the
transaction here so so this split at
this moment has nothing to do with
transactions it's it is only taking out
the row of voting and put it into a
separate type of blocks that's all okay
all right so you may say okay yes
what is the incentive to vote so right
now we're not talking about incentive
right so so so okay so there is some
incentive to vote because if you don't
vote you will not get transactions into
the ledger really because otherwise you
cannot get block rewards you cannot get
transaction rewards right okay well I
haven't finished a protocol yet so I
haven't finished developed protocol yet
but maybe we can come back to this issue
when the hope for the cause developed
okay all right yeah how's this picture
different from the left being blocked
headers the right being block headers in
the left ding blocks like there's
exactly one proposal block that's
exactly the same size so this picture is
only a cartoon picture in general that
doesn't have to be a one-to-one
correspondence at all so you have soft
two things growing in parallel okay
actually it's not finished yet let me
finish first I think is thank you very
much there are some kind people are not
messing you're not kind by okay all
right so you may say why do I split this
structure right this seems that rather
complicated because there was a one nice
longest chain why does this plinth or
you have a question already okay all
right yes that's right exactly
thank you very much you asked the
perfect question there okay at this
point I have done nothing I haven't done
[ __ ] right at this point okay because
actually I say that the this mining
right and this mana is the same as
before I did not actually increase
neither the money rate so you're right
so the voting rate remains the same here
okay
but now the next step is that once you
break up in two parts then there's a
natural question the natural method
we're just now instead of having one
voted chain I can now have many many
separate boring chains and all of them
can do the same thing which is to vote
for the proposal block so now
intuitively speaking it's more intuitive
then my voting rate has indeed increased
so if I have say 1,000 voting chains
which then my voting rate is increased
by a factor of 1,000 although I keep the
mining rate here and every chain the
same as before say one block every ten
minutes okay a one block every twenty
seconds in this area yes because even
the first one took you ten now you're
agreed by thousand charming ten thousand
times I mean you need more amount of
computation if the mining rate is same
but is just increasing you're just
paralyzing but it's not reducing the
amount of tasks they pazzo to solve is
easier for every block now right for
every block is easier so let me let me
go to that
okay all right okay so good so good good
good so this pink block as you can see
there no links anymore right but
actually it is also growing on a longest
chain it is also growing long chain
longest chain there but I'm no longer
using as long as chain to do
confirmation so I remove it from picture
but however the longest chain does give
me one thing which is for every block
there's a depth in this longest trait in
this tree and I'm using a depth to order
it okay so in other words the picture
you should think is that at each depth
there is one or more block there could
be alternative block right for example
anniversary could create some
alternative light in public or in
private but I'm using the levels to sort
of to define my competitions
and so is it fair to say that the
difference between this and just having
a larger block size is that with a
larger block size it's all or nothing
because here I can vote for two blocks
and you could vote for one of those two
blocks like that the older of the two
blocks that I'm voted for it so we would
somehow reinforce each other the ability
to kind of vote for some of the
transactions of whether where someone
else is going for larger set is that the
kind of nugget that's gonna make this
okay alright so maybe the the Nugget is
the following in the longest chain you
when your wait for one vote that one
vote may come in five minutes or may
come in ten minutes
or may come in 15 minutes okay then it's
kind of random and so if the wait a long
time to Arish out that reminisce so that
you can make sure that divert sri cannot
by chance with but now here I have many
votes come in like fluid so then it's
much more regular and then intuitively I
don't have to wait that long anymore to
get certainty of winning over the
adversary so this is a variance
reduction strategy
on the proposal folks right Spencer yes
yes yes so at this moment it's just
intuitive I will go to more detail into
the doubles pants and exits right okay
let me do it step by step okay all right
so now have many of only chain and
intuitively I've loaded it and say I
haven't stay any theorems yet but this
is the intuition okay now let's just say
a few words about this scheme so first
of all I need a mechanism to sortition
my blocks into the orange blocks and the
blue blocks and among the blue blocks I
need to sort ition into 1000 different
voter change so 1,000 different types of
blocks okay and I will use a method is
invented in the grey paper it's called -
for mine - for one my name also used in
passing she fruit chain paper which is
basically used the output of the hash to
split into different type of locks so
that the adversary cannot focus is power
on any one of these volume chains okay
so it's like a random sortition but that
bursary cannot control okay so that's
the first one that's how we have
different types of blocks - is how do i
construct a ledger
okay first I count votes but only if the
vote is from the longest chain of its
respective voting tree okay so the chain
in some sense tells you what are the
valid votes number one number two is for
each level I simply choose the proposer
block with most votes with most votes
okay all right so that's it yeah
you're talking about jeans yes we agree
that we need to maintain chains so you
can excuse that you have a chain yes
exactly exactly so I am drawing this for
simplicity but there could be forking
here and you know I've limited space on
this slide so I would like to if I were
have infinite space I would like to draw
a tree right on each one of them and
this is just the main chain of the
longest chain of that tree and our only
count votes on that longest chain so for
a given
proposing block you look at all the
woods that have come in yes that's right
okay you only look at those words that
came from the long distance change not
be careful not the longest of the 1000
but each one has the longest chain so
it's 1000 longest chains yes okay
sorry how is what
yes that that's when I talked about a
security proof right so first I would
just just to give an intuition of what
the scheme looks like okay and then I
will state as security theorems and then
I will go into how I would prove it
intuitively high level because of this
picture it's random right is random so
yeah I mean is this sorry I should next
time I draw a picture change those
thousand one thousand ones chains made
actually different exactly exactly yeah
this is just a picture sorry
this picture is too too regular yes
sorry come again I think quite a thing
we know how to watch yes it's thousand
chains of voting single chain
no no so this is a so-called two-for-one
mining let me explain it a little bit so
imagining your minor when you mind
actually you don't know what kind of
blocks you're gonna get okay and this
random sortition process once you get
your soft opposed oh there's a ha ha ok
you solve the puzzle but it has a
particular hash value and depending on
that hash value
it was sorting you into one of these
1,000 chains plus one one thousand plus
one okay and then you get attached to it
so the adversary cannot say oh I don't
like these these two boring chain let me
just focus all my power mining them you
cannot do that it's very important this
is very important okay all right yes
you know in VN that we sing maybe worse
ma because you will be put you will be
when you prepare the block you have to
assume the 1000 possible scenario yes
but then of course when you actually put
the block in you don't have you can just
put a Merc of proof and the contact with
that particular block we understand is
this are you applying the law of large
large numbers across space is that your
over time space yeah so that's the
that's how answer David's question which
is that when you go longer and longer
you are sort of waiting over time to
average out your randomness your very
reduce your variance but here I'm
averaging over some space because I'm
doing this in parallel good all right
okay so all right so at this moment I
have now have a scheme with intuitively
potentially low latency however I have
not increased a throughput yet okay so
to increase the throughput we followed
this the construction process one more
step we take out these transactions and
put it in transaction blocks and again
these transaction blocks are created
through a sortition process and only the
transaction blocks carry transaction
these guys now do not carry transaction
what they do is when you mind them you
insert pointers to transaction blocks
that have not been referred to before
and so when you now get confirmed a
proposal blocks then it brings along
with at the transaction blocks and those
transactions enter into the ledger ok so
that is how we you know need to increase
the block size so effectively we
increase in the block size but we're not
this proposal block size is not
increased
and so there's no serious [ __ ]
problem along this structure okay so
that's how we increase the throughput
okay so this is prism okay all right so
now the key idea here that we use is the
coupling idea okay and this idea has
been used before in particular it has
been used by decoupling transactions
from proposing in Bitcoin energy and in
fruit chain both of these ideas this
idea has been used before but Bitcoin
and G has different its focuses on
transactions only and you propose
transactions only after you get proposed
you enter win the lottery okay and that
is a big difference to us because we
actually do not do that and this has
subject to bribing attack because of
that fruit chain focuses on fairness but
they're using a decoupling ideas here so
what we are doing here is we are
basically following the decoupling
principle we're carrying to the extreme
which is weekly couple everything
transactions proposing and voting and
voting and then we can scale everything
independently so that we can
simultaneously get good food and good
allegiance there okay so a natural
question now is okay so now you have
this degree of freedom that you can
scale so how far can one scale and at
this point you are kind of limited by
physical constraints physical
constraints so in other words before we
were limited by security so if the
throughput was limited by security and
now we're limited by physical
constraints for example there's an
example of a physical constraint it's
like a communication link 200 megabits
per second or it could be some compute
power that limits you from validation
you also limited by the propagation
delay okay so basically our security
theorem will say that our performance
throughput is limit or this number and a
latency is limited with this number
okay so what are the theorems so I rush
spent a lot of time talking about the
security motives so since this talk is
about a new protocol so we're not going
to be able to talk much about that but
thank you thankfully rush mentioned all
that and took her other questions and so
here I would only say that the model
here is simply a synchronous model very
simple model a synchronous model
following the Bitcoin backbone protocol
paper gkl 17 okay plus a rather simple
communication model which essentially
put a constraint on how many blocks one
can generate as a function of the
communication bandwidth the C okay so
the security theorem basically says the
following first prizm achieves
consistency and liveness okay whenever
the inverse requires less than 0.5 so
this property says that I do not do
worse than Bitcoin security wise I'm at
the same level as Bitcoin number two the
throughput is you can achieve something
proportional to C times 1 minus beta 1
month beta C where beta is the
adversary' fraction of power so you can
get pretty close to see if 3 for latency
prism
can confirm honest transaction with
probability 1 minus epsilon so epsilon
is just security parameter the latency
is given by some constant times D the
network delay plus D divided by M where
m is the number of voting chains so
1,000 for example times log of 1 over
Epsilon okay so that's the result I will
explain a little later what it means by
confirming honest transaction
but first let's see some pictures okay
so the throughput curve as a function of
beta this is the one much better see
this is what prism can achieve and to
compare the red is what Bitcoin can
achieve okay so when I say big conical
shape I'm optimizing over all the money
rate and the block size to get this
curve and you can see that as you get
close to 0.5 the throughput of Bitcoin
as a fraction of the capacity network
bandwidth goes to zero and this is a
security constraint of Bitcoin and prism
does not have this constraint so this 1
minus beta really comes from a denial
service attack because the adversary has
power beta so we can deny that fraction
of the capacity but essentially prism is
optimal because it can get the rest okay
in terms of latency what's the picture
there is that if you think of your plot
as a function of the security parameter
epsilon the latency Bitcoin increases
the latency increases as a security
parameter goes smaller and smaller yeah
so okay so it turns out the following
intuitively there seems to be trade-off
between m and the throughput okay but in
practice this trade-off is very mild and
the reason is because the voting blocks
are actually very small they only
contain a hash to a vote where's the
transaction blocks a gigantic like 1000
times the size in our implementation so
you can just sort of ignore that and so
there's really no trade-off and
essentially you can delegate 99 percent
of your total bandwidth to the
transaction blocks and the rest only
takes that one percent so this is
assuming that situation yeah that's
right so if you like to be precise you
can give say 90 percent
need to get 0.9 times 1 minus beta C
okay now the latency what happened yeah
so the kink is the following this curve
is security limitation is limited by
security this part is limited by your
bandwidth
okay so prism what happens is that the
latency increases at a rate which is
reduced by a factor of M in the prison
in the in the where m is number volume
change so this M tells you that you have
an effective increase in your voting
rate by a factor of M and that reduces
latency that sort of theory carboys up
out the intuition okay and at this point
you basically have the security
parameter is of the order of M so as I
increase the number of voting chain
which have love flexibility increase
this curve becomes flat and flatter and
essentially you're hitting the
propagation delay limit over a very wide
range of security parameter very small
security parameter so that's in that
sense I'm we're hitting the physical
limit okay all right so so let's go to a
little bit more deep into the intuition
okay so why can I get fast confirmation
okay so so before we need it to get
small epsilon we need like say 24 book
deep or 25 block D in the longest chain
here so that you can deny a double
spange okay a private that was bad so
here you have 1,000 voting chain and so
one way of getting confirmation is the
following you can wait until these all
these chains becomes 24 deep and now
each of these votes are secure because
what does the act I could do the
attacker will try to change your vote by
growing a side chain so for example you
vote on something it will try to shift a
vote to my private block so you can have
a very long chain very long chain 24 bit
then each of these votes are very secure
and then a number of votes on this block
is also very secure and then you can
confirm this as a leader block for that
we call this a leader block okay all
right
they claim though is that we don't need
to do this
we don't need 24 block did all we need
is to block people why is that so to
block deep the confirmation reversal
property is very bad we have 45 percent
forty five percent you can calculate
that from nakamoto's table analysis but
the point is that the event I'm
interested in is what is the event is
that I want 500 volts to be reverted so
the anniversary if they were displace
this book has to be able to revert 500
of these 1000 volts okay so that it can
show this block and say oh it has more
votes so the confirmation transformation
will be reversed in here okay now what's
the probability of having fathered votes
revert well the reversal on each chain
is point four five point four five so on
the average the adversary will be able
to revert how many votes for four or
five times 1000 volts
450 volts so what's the chance of having
500 in step 14 15 that property is right
a small point zero zero one okay and
this property is precisely the at law of
large number that was discussed earlier
and so that's the intuition okay sorry
yes so that that's what I'm gonna talk
about right now
so this intuition three minutes okay so
I guess my student will be a set set
because I can't do a demo anymore so we
actually you have to have the demo
okay all right so okay so to make this
result precise okay prove this result
what you basically need to do is to
prove a sort of a macroscopic chain
quality and common prefix of these
volume change you basically want to say
that a large fraction of these chains
have to follow common prefix with this
probability four five the adversary can
act hack all these chains in a
correlative fashion so it is true it's
not independent by through this analysis
we can show similar results anyway okay
all right so that's roughly the story
now there is a little bit more
complicated Ori now I have three just
have three minutes right including the
demo but I want to say one thing here
which is since is a consensus community
here a very natural question is hey how
come I only have one block here that I'm
voting for what happens if I have two
blocks so for example the adversary can
publish one block in parallel to the
honors block and tries to steer the vote
for example
so that you have a near time I think
that's the question that Dalia asked me
earlier so I thought I'd show this okay
ty near time okay so one thing you
notice is that I never actually
described what the voting method is it
turns out our announcers holds for any
boring method as long as you vote so
that's important you vote what happens
if you get to this situation okay
can we now confirm the block was firing
one vote with only two block tip no
because I have a law of large number but
I cannot avoid you from reversing one or
two votes so I cannot okay however what
we can confirm is that you've at least
one of these what exactly one of these
two blocks will be in the final edge in
other words the adversary cannot create
a third block okay and that is enough to
do a lot of things for example if a
particular transaction appears in both
that I can immediately confirm them even
if a transaction only appears in one
then it turns out that if I wait for the
next level and there's a uniquely honest
block and I can use this block to refer
to this transaction that now I can also
confirm it the only situation in which I
cannot confirm is if there's an explicit
double spend on two blocks in that case
I cannot confirm any more of them but
then and now after winning two 24-volt
deep to get the final ordering in other
words to remove one of them so that's
why I'll Rizzo is only for honest
transactions which are not public double
Spence
okay actions that have an expiration
tries transaction so you don't watch my
country I guess right these two blocks
but we don't know if this yeah basically
a smart contract
yeah so we have not done a very detailed
analysis to be on sort of the UTX Oh
model in terms of sequence of
transaction so I don't know if I can
answer this question in like two minutes
yeah so so that's why we talk about
beyond you take so it allows temporal
transactions okay but Donley wants me to
show the demo thing so great I don't
even know if I can show the demo right
now because I don't know if I've network
connection here
sit because Cal visitor cannot allow me
they have blocked off my okay all right
I can't show demo well this was you can
cut into you yeah oh I can connect to my
phone that is true let me try that let
my phone went off you guys give me 30
seconds
is it okay sure sure
show me so this is be back by the way
okay why are you showing them oh okay so
we implemented this protocol Amy from
scratch and rust and after six months of
work to be variable do get this demo and
so this demo has hundred notes connected
with like a folding layer on the ground
each node is an AWS machine and each and
now you started this machine
bootstrapped it with by just giving each
user certain constant amount of coins
and then we started running the protocol
and the performance of the protocol can
be broken down into three different
parts
what is the true put the other one is
the latency and the last one is for king
which is as we can see that we've been
running this as 30 minutes of mana and
the average throughput of the system is
roughly 70,000 transactions per second
and the confirmation Leighton's these 23
seconds because mining raters one block
every 10 seconds so as you see two
blocks deep fried of
examples and we know that the security
of the longest in protocol is very much
tied to the forking rate of the system
and because also obtains its security
because of the voting chains which in
turn follow the longest state because
the falling rate here is this 10% which
shows that this protocol has security of
about 47% so yeah any questions
regarding me 10% of folks this yeah
that means 10% of the blocks are not
part of the main chain so the more you
the larger the [ __ ] readers the lower
your security is so this is the
dashboard I know you you also have a
nice animation of the system animation
there Dali wants to see the animation
anyone
this is a very demanding
I was blown away when I select this yeah
so big so I left already but the voting
cannot equal Lance as you can see so you
can see that the boarding chains are
voting for these blocks and when they
get fit that means they confirm already
and the transaction blocks are coming
out like a pool and then whenever
proposal get mind can attach hashes to
the transaction book they can see in the
pool and then the foodies transaction
blocks in to create this serialize
ledger so that's how this wasn't worth
it
[Applause]
thank you baby
[Music]